good evening father books good
afternoon to others thank you very much for
joining us until almost the end of this
conference edition and I want now I
want to be especially the
organizers of this event for giving us
this space for discussion in Spanish
as you venerate line my name is micaela
rica I am  Professor of the virtual
library and I am in charge of the
animal facility of the Faculty of
Biological Sciences of the Pontificia
Universidad Católica de Chile, listen to the
exam because, in reality, she is
also part of the
board of directors of making chicanas, which is the
Chilean Association of Margin Sciences.
Laboratorio y Defensa Cal is the
federation that brings together all the
laboratory animal science associations from South America.
In this talk, what I am going to try to
show you is the contribution of the
distance education modality in
working with laboratory animals, but
specifically in countries  from
latin america where there is a fu  There is a strong trend towards an
increase in the use of animals in
research and academics,
while in other parts of the world,
the trend is focused on the
development of shoes to replace
living beings and thus does not
force a number of animals to be  they use
ok it seems that we are a little in the
situation of latin america' discount
that there are very few countries that have
training offers
both at the initial level and
continuously and with this I want to say that
there are many other places where the
training of the  people who
work with laboratory animals
it is done by inheritance what does
this mean that someone with many years of
experience but is in formal training
or updates explains
to new people how they should
work with animals and I think
most of us  They know how this ends
and it is precisely in people bitten
by poorly done techniques and results
that if they are obtained many times they
are invalid because the truth is that
we started badly from the dealer but the most
important thing at this point is that the errors have an
impact on the welfare of the
animals
the truth is that they are
multiple and at all levels from the most
basic how to handle animals
holding them up to the most complex technique
or the most complex surgery worst of
all is that these poorly done practices
have been carried over the
years this talk is a presentation of
the advances we have been able to
collect throughout  the years in this
implementation of the
remote occasion modality in the area of
procedures with
laboratory animals precisely for
Spanish-speaking countries to break a little
this chain of poorly done procedures
in regions where even today there is
no possibility of training
ok let's start  So submitting them is a
bit about the subject of technology,
our support, I know it's good, we
're going to get involved.  very in detail, but if
we do the experiment of putting
the word tics or information and communication technologies in a search on the internet,
we will find a lot
of computer resources that can
be applied in many instances of
our daily life but speaking of the
application of these  technologies in
education we can leave the search to
take only those that allow us to
contribute to our final objective of
training but they also have to
be easy to understand and manage to
ensure that the
training by the students
was well assimilated
in short, the tics  They are instruments
that we have at our fingertips, but
we have to know how to
apply them correctly, of
course, the instruments are ready
to be applied along the way.
Let's define what distance education is.
We have more than a
teaching and learning strategy in the  that
distance and time play the
fundamental role  In distance education, the
teacher and the student are
physically distant and use one or another
technology to communicate and
exchange information. In turn, this
modality of education can be
synchronous, that is to say, that there is an
exchange of information at the same
time, or asynchronous in which  The
teacher student are in
different places and times. The
characteristics of this modality,
especially the interactivity,
also allows the participants to
carry out activities individually
or in groups throughout the course of the
program. However
, distance education
is not  only the exchange of
information and response of the
distance student the development of this type of
education implies a set of
challenges that we have to address so
that the product that this delivery is
appropriate to the characteristics of the
students targeted by the program that
we offer and  on the other hand to
the competitions  that we want to
develop through the student
at the end of the program let's remember
that we are going to see all this from the
application in Latin American countries
where resources and goods are scarce
are not distributed
equitably
and such was this distribution is accentuated
because the distances are  very large in
our training centers
ok what is happening today at the level of
virtual education in latin america
reality shows us that
distance education is nowadays in the focus
of educational strategies at
different levels and the trend is
increasing only in the  In 2003, as you can
see in the graph,
continuous distance education led the distribution
with respect to other educational offers
in Latin America and Caribbean countries,
and this is due to several factors, but
mainly to the economic geographic ones
, the possibility of access and  the
less time that the student has to
spend on these programs,
the truth is that there is no d  The most
current data published but
surely the indicators
have either been maintained or have increased
very well, leaving behind the
introduction of this technology,
we will then proceed to the implementation
of virtual training in
procedures with
laboratory animals from our perspective
as a virtual classroom.  Mystery this
master's question in 2007, when
compiling the educational offer available
only in Argentina, interestingly
arose as a response that all formal
training and
training instances at that time
were centered no more than 50
kilometers from the autonomous city of
Buenos Aires de la  capital of Argentina
and in reality there are many
rural research centers with
universities and private institutions
that use animals in laboratories
distributed throughout the country
in this highly centralized reading was what
prompted us to offer training in
this matter sole of
urban sounds  trying to overcome the
obstacle of distances,
from there we began to investigate a
lot, we advised them, we took many
technology courses in
computer minutes and finally we jumped into
the pool with the formation of a
virtual bioterio classroom in 2008, which
is nothing more than  a
specific thematic virtual learning environment on
laboratory animal sciences that
contains a series of sections and
tools that we will see later in
detail
this is your inspiration it
allows us to plan and offer
training courses and problems
training point initial and advanced
through  de internet
estudia continues in 2008
when we prepared the first pilot course
on the topic of factors that
negatively affect work with laboratory animals.
This first pilot was actually
aimed at a level of
beginner students in the topics that we
were addressing were the different factors
both physical and chemical  biological
that affected the daily work for
animals plus a biosafety module
via telex the life themes in
modules and the total duration was
four weeks. Initially we wanted to
limit the quota to 30 people to
test the computer platform and so
that the students could  make the
most of the tools on the platform,
the technology and the materials at that
time, the truth is that they were very, very
simple for each topic of study, they
were given some reading that they could
download from the virtual classroom to their
computer and then those readings were reinforced
by  through consultations that the
students made through the forums
at the end at the end of each week the
student carries out a passion evaluation and
at the end of the entire program making
a final evaluation
in the students who obtained more than 60
points and had tolerated a
certificate of approval
in this pilot course we had
participants from argentina many but
fundamental p  But also Brazil from
Chile Colombia Cuba in Mexico in
Argentina for example and only done and
interact with students who
were 3000 kilometers from Buenos
Aires from the federal capital the truth
that caused us a great impact and made us
want to continue advancing in this  because
precisely one of the objectives we
had in mind was pressure to carry out
this type of training from the big cities.
The truth is that from the
first attempt we arrived at the city at the
end of the world, which is how
the city of Ushuaia, Tierra del del Mundo, is known in Argentina.
When this pilot course ends,
we informally ask the students that they
will value their experience because it will be a
33.
We have to leave three more
and some aspects of this
learning modality and we conclude
that the most relevant in their view was
the availability of materials and  access
to the platform at all times the
personalized tutorials because in the
discussion forums that we proposed l  The students
could comment on examples or ask
about the topic in particular or share
problems, but as long as they
were related to the theme
of the course,
we also greatly appreciate the
exchange of experiences with other
students through the forum
because the experiences of other colleagues
have many  debates that
enriched many forums and finally
the language the language was very relevant
because practically all the biography
that is available information in
this area is in English and still in
Latin America and a large percentage of
people who do not speak the language
very well
once  Once we had completed this
pilot experience, we were able to carry out the
first course on
experimental procedures in rats and mice. This
program was aimed at
technical, technical and auxiliary professionals
and we specially prepared it
so that it would be useful and interesting for a
wide spectrum of
Spanish-speaking people who did not  They had  experience for
this educational modality
the truth that extending and we are going to give
new editions and we improve and
update it with information that is
coming out day by day in each one of them
the key to this opportunity of the first
course of procedures
was to
look for an educational platform but with
a very lonely computer infrastructure,
so this was our
first need and in two we
paid all our attention to be able to
provide students with friendly and
easy-to-use tools that also
met the requirements of
administrations, specific functions,
technical support and technical support as
well  played a key role in this
stage because the robot has the
platform where it was mounted in all
the programs, always in Ávila,
accompanied by technical support capable of
giving an immediate response
regarding the platform, the tips currently on the
market, an infinity of attractive offers,
free books  then we have in
hea  rt the search to meet the
needs of our courses or
program and not get lost in the search
another aspect that we consider is the
specialization of the instructors in
more precise computer aspects
that is why we as teachers had to
take many courses and training them
both linearly and  in computing
because the reality is that it is not enough to manage
the educational platform, but to optimize
the use of all the tools that are
in it.
The truth is that today, in terms
of infrastructure factors, it continues to be a
limitation, since
initial and
constant new economic investments are required to  making the leap to the
virtualization of materials and the
subsequent investments are also
important to write to acquire
our specialized software to
virtualize
the contents of the best possible quality
ok to cover all the needs or
at least we tried to make it so that
the students later identified  of the
pilot  we use are some of the
tools available on the
platform that we chose because the way
of delivering information and the materials
must also be gradual, he says to set
guidelines in advance, thinking that for
some students this is their first
experience or approach with the
virtual modality, therefore it is not  it can
be overwhelming in this way we also
ensure the student a pleasant and
calm environment for work and communication
speaking the tool is one that
we always use it
is the introduction in
the course description section today we explain in
detail to the students how it
works  of the course in its
distance modality how it is made up of
the teaching staff how to find what
was studied the videos the
approval requirements and as I said before
this is the first contact with our
virtual modality with which the
information must be delivered as
clearly and  simple as possible another section is
the agenda that serves to  So that students
can view the course program
in different daily, weekly,
and monthly formats and visualize the beginning of
completion of module work
, evaluation dates, etc.,
the announcements tool was the
notification channel through which the tutor
sends notifications to students  or
important reminders to your email
in food documents we upload
all the study materials so
that students can later download them to their
profile or name in it in the case
of videos
but the truth is that at home we always
recommend downloading it so you can
do  more agile the platform the sale
exercise as I said before there
we put the interactive tests the
evaluations that can be multiple of
the open response to
interactive zones that are not only made up of
text but can have images or
animations in general we are improving
in cases of  daily life
and finally the privileges that we are going to
see a little  From the details
below, as a tool that was
very, very well received,
we also put some links to
bring students closer to
reliable places to look for updated information,
luckily today we have our
resources, I recommend bioterios
dotcom, a Latin American portal where
there are specialists who have spoken in
these sessions and they are very very simple
very generous with the
information finally in the tools the chat
this is the truth is that it is a
tool closely associated with the students
we can schedule sessions
the truth is that we leave it 24
hours because if it is not lost  the focus
of teaching but if we do
scheduled chats and where a
particular topic is debated or outside the
topic of the course itself
to give students a more open space
about visual resources at
first, as I told you before, no
they were of the best quality but little by
little we were incorporating new
programs  s that allowed us
to show details of each
high definition technique and thus
the importance of having
a solid platform is clear because they send the
best visual resources are in high
quality on the other hand it is also
important that the platform where
our program is mounted is  capable of
supporting the access of several users
simultaneously,
well, as I told you, the
most active tools are the pages, which in turn
are moderated by tutors of the course,
teachers, and they talk exclusively
about the topics of program one, are
social forums and social networks,
great the course  of the course program
we organize several separated
by topics which are gradually enabled
in due time
it is always a good practice that the first
message is made by the tutor who invites
the students remembering the
work guidelines and the truth is that our
our role as  teacher is
September encourage participation  n
of all,
among the things in the background, it is also useful
for them to only ask us questions about
the material that we give them,
but also for them to share
personal experiences, contributing ideas
or generating discussions, and this is
the rather golden part of the forum,
well, let's see what  The students have
the student degenerate into enjoying having
many tools, sections,
labyrinths, search, find, however,
we as teachers must
be careful to moderate the amount of
tools that are offered to them
because the focus of the training is not lost,
yes
in reality in these forums.  they should not
acquire greater prominence than the
educational action itself; on the other hand, it is
important to remember that technology
by itself does not generate
educational content, that content is
generated by people, therefore
technology can do very good things, it
can make life easier for us, but it
only goes  to work if combined
with an educational idea  concrete tive in
our case and with the
human capacities that perform them
well to tell you about some of the
results we had after each
course we analyzed some characteristics
of the enrollees and throughout these
measurements are the resources of
procedures with a while and mice
we had students
Most of them participated from 16 countries, although they were from
Argentina, we also had students from
Curva Mexico, Brazil, Spain, Colombia and
Chile, and to a lesser extent from Venezuela, El
Salvador, but one from Puerto Rico, Uruguay,
Bolivia, Canada, Ecuador and Paraguay, which
led us to think that there really is
interest.  In almost all the countries in
Latin America to participate
and we also use a lot of attention in
the people from Spain and Canada who
participated. We are grateful because it was a
very very rich exchange of experiences.
Another interesting fact that we obtained was
that the age spectrum with the greatest
participation of 46  % in this case
belongs to the
corresponding age range  Where do the doctorates with
doctorates or principal investigators go?
Today we saw
Patrick's presentation, who told us about the need
for this group, precisely who continually seeks to
train in our
scams
to corroborate this 46%. We focused on
the different transfusions
and how the story told them.  The person version
is professionals with
a contested undergraduate degree. In
our opinion, the idea of
training for animals is concrete, since in
many university careers they are fewer
in Latin America, for example, well,
chemistry, medicine, biology,
dentistry, etc. Even
veterinarians taught us to work with
animals.  laboratory, but if they are used
as experimental models, another fact
that we do not pay much attention to is
that most of these students take
courses to verify if what they
learned to be by inheritance, as was
said before, is so, it is good, it is not
good and  It did not come out of the times,
this information was not correct  rmation about the professions,
and also the little that is
invested in training the
lower levels, that is, the technicians, I have one
of the assistants, despite the
need to have
support personnel who work correctly, no
money is invested in their training and  On the
other hand, since they are the ones who
earn the least in this ladder, they are not trained
to continue improving the
mine's offer in laboratory animals.
We put the participants well in the brief
survey at the end of 2013
at random from our
database.  data that had participated in
previous courses and last 95 90 of
them would recommend this
training modality because according to them it
partly replaces the use of
pre-experienced animals for manual work,
well which confirms that this
modality of distance education is
quite efficient  in meet the
objectives that we set ourselves at the
beginning of this parade
and some advantages that we  The students pointed out
when taking this type of
training were the convenience, the
flexibility of the schedule to access
the materials, the 24-hour online access,
which are obviously
cheaper and we award many
scholarships on site, the investment in trips
and stays in  our countries remember
that the distances are very long, they
were really significant,
our objective was fulfilled when
they pointed out that it gives them the real
possibility of training,
precisely to people from places
disconnected from any center and who
do not have the possibility of traveling, a
clear example of these are  Cuban students,
on the other hand, pointed out to us that it is in
accordance with the principle of the three Rs
since the previous visualization, as I told them,
decreases and corrects errors
during learning practices
and courses, bringing users closer to
updated techniques so that they can
refine their procedures directly.
in their
works last the you  stories that were
personalized because in the
discussion forums real cases
that health quickly raise are resolved
and in the disadvantages because there are always
disadvantages that remain the same
as at the beginning of this venture
and that should happen to all those who
try to formalize this  type of
learning is that this
instance modality does not have face-to-face practices
, however, it can be the
previous complement to the hanson practices,
so distance education, on the
other hand, we can say that it is only
suitable for motivated people since
working independently requires
a  certain discipline and follow-up, and
finally, it requires that the student
have basic knowledge of
computers, PC management and internet access
very well.
The truth is that
distance education in the animal in the laboratory
is still in an initial period and of
constant changes.  and some of the
requests we had from the
students was j  Just from the program of
webinars or online seminars that we gave you
last year and we had the
possibility of developing two types: a
program for people who were just
starting out in animal work and
the man who loves consisted of more
specific and more advanced techniques for people who
I already had previous experience; currently,
these programs are
available on demand and, as I was
saying, sometimes they cover very specific topics
or very specific techniques,
but the truth is that the strength of these
training courses that we have proposed
are the courses on experimental procedures,
well, in short, what  that we did since
six years old because they advanced through their pilot
to see how we were doing then closet
offers the course of procedures in
rats and mice we also added before
experimental procedures in rabbits
we had approximately 750 students in
total distributed in 16 countries of
which 200 of them
these scholarships were sins we gave ourselves  god
spontaneously or through the portal
previous story dotcom through
the Cuban society of
laboratory animals of the Mexican society
of Argentina and the Chilean society that are
our sponsors also then there
is and also an
interesting network of collaborations is formed
and also thanks to  contribution of some
sponsors we were able to want more
computer technologies and here I
would like to emphasize that our goal is not
economic but is precisely to try
to break that chain of technical ways
to take our training to
distant places therefore we give
many many scholarships in each  program and
also thanks to the sponsorship we were able to
join islands as an associate member
and we really share the same
objectives of promoting and eliminating
international collaboration
humane treatment of experimental animals
always being the
principle is 30 replace reduce and
receive
here we are the  stable team that
makes u  na viento del bioterio is made up of
carolina móviles, who was the founder of
this idea, the founders, ideas whom you will
meet in the following talk, emilia
de armero in the anger of the medium,
those two are argentine and emigrate,
currently working the battery of the
italian hospital in buenos aires  in argentina and
well those who speak but also together with
the three stables we have
external advisers on some specific issues
to complete the group
very well as a conclusion because
this methodology is very late in some
countries and ends up applied to
laboratory animal procedures
although it cannot replace 100% of
the practices assumptions but it
was very useful as a
complementary resource for animal users
to familiarize themselves with the
techniques and increase and refine
knowledge before undertaking the
face-to-face regulation also all the
advantages are  that you create networks of
collaboration between students for
fut  ure communications and collaborations
contributes a lot to the reduction in the
number of animals, since by refining the
techniques we show,
the unnecessary use of animals
for practices is
also reduced at this point, I would also like to
tell you that all the animals that
we use in the
visual means to show the practices
were already part of
experimental protocols with which we are not
extra animals we try to maximize by
optimizing each student
well this is our website we invite you
to take a walk if you want some of
the plans we have for this year
include
As you can see, they have some
train the train marks talks on
the teacher level. The truth is that we have been doing this task for years and now we have been
doing this for
between 12 and 15 years,
starting with the renewed editions of the
courses, but I also want to make a
special invitation.  and extensive to
specialists who want to develop
seminars or programs  more than aiming at the
humane treatment of laboratory animals
everyone is welcome to
our website so you can contact us
through this part here we are
work on the form and we will
contact you shortly
and this is as far as we come so
I thank you for  pay attention to this
modality towards training
and if anyone wants to ask a question they
are welcome at this time
and before I leave I invite them to come to
the stand of the Chilean association which
I think is located but well
look for us there we
are very close to the writer  ian from the
argentine association
and well you can also find us I
know that we stayed a little while but
on the pink page girls also these
guys to the point cl so they are
welcome
well let's go with the topic of the
questions
there are greetings
there is a question
someone from  Argentina asks me if
they plan to do courses that are not
just our follow-up
experiments
If we plan to do not only
procedures, our
real knowledge course, I counted very well, but
we have thematic modules. You
can find the theme on the
website
and it is the courts.
same training we launched
part of the course category be faithful until
they are buenos aires-argentina
unfortunate the practices so they are
similar nothing more than the technology the
truth is that today it is much more
advanced and it allows us to
show this type of detail
yes  We plan to do other types of
courses but well all ideas are
welcome so I'll know
another bug question using the
course related to surgery
yes it would be good we have some webinars
on surgical techniques
aseptic techniques and pump implants
and select lines that also
so  If you want any surgery in
particular, do not hesitate to contact us,
you are always welcome.  The ideas are gone,
they ask me something, the practices do
not need to
be practical, but
the truth is that, as we explained,
this is a good approach, it is a first
approach to contact with animals,
especially for people who do not have
experience. The truth is that  It helps us a
lot to refine the field techniques later,
but we always suggest that they be
accompanied by a tutor who knows this
technique in detail, that is, handling,
organization of substances, taking
samples, it is always good to have a tutor
by your side who can accompany us and
correct the problems.  errors,
we are analyzing the truth,
we have some proposals for
centers to go in situ after the
groups or people take the
virtual training, so we are
analyzing this type of complement in
person and well, hopefully
we will be happy to be able to visit us,
so  good
if the existence is possible to edit thing
of vivienne security of vari  The teams
are fine in English and if everything is possible
everything is possible to set up so nothing
welcome about us if you
want I'll put the page back and
as I was saying the truth is that our
objective is not economic we look for another
type of end all the  Ideas are
welcome.
They tell me to give me the courses, not with
her, but you can visit the website
better, if you don't, you're not here in Miami tomorrow. The
truth is that we
really enjoyed
developing
the different sections, they are the
visual resources, so this feedback is super good.
that we are having
thank you very much for all the greetings
if we offer scholarships write us
if we deal with work groups for
example
and they ask us to train a group in
particular
nothing we make a special sensation a
magnet for a group of
specific students and we can even refine the
techniques according to each  In any case, it is the same
institution that does toxicology and
another that does neurology, for example,
so there the  contents are adapted
that is totally feasible
in my institution there are scholarships but we
are freckles
so
good I think that's all for
now thank you it has been a pleasure to
participate with so many
dear teachers so good I say goodbye until
the next edition god